one of the best things about doing the
critical rendering path analysis is you
can get a pretty good estimate for how
long the page will take to render yeah
it's pretty awesome once I have my
critical rendering path diagram I don't
even have to profile my page well I do
need to profile my page for other
bottlenecks but what I mean is that I
can see all the dependencies in my
critical rendering path diagram and get
a good idea of how long my page is going
to take to render exactly a little bit
of practice you can just take a look at
the HTML and figure out what the
critical rendering path is and you know
what that's actually a great exercise
I'm going to give you a couple of files
which you can find in the instructor
notes and why don't you analyze those
draw the diagrams and come up with the
CRP metrics so should I draw a diagram
like the ones we've been seeing in the
examples yep exactly and don't worry
about making it pretty use whatever
tools you like pen-and-paper is good and
then post it on the forum all right
so make sure I've got the three critical
rendering path metrics - the critical
path length the number of critical
resources and the number of critical
bytes yep exactly
cool so I'll go ahead and post it on the
forums